[Musique]
jean pierre prévôt 26 ans a tenu de
nombreux emplois temporaires avant de
vendre des vêtements sur les marchés de
la région de pontoise salomon une gare
et 25 ans d'origine sénégalaise en
france depuis cinq ans comptable et
agent commercial de formation il préfère
gagner sa vie en travaillant sur les
marchés avec ses amis franck fontaine 19
ans père d'un garçon de deux mois et
demi exerce depuis plusieurs années le
métier de forain d'abord avec sa mère et
ensuite avec son ami jean pierre prévôt
c'était à cergy pontoise le 26 novembre
il était 4 heures du matin et les trois
amis s'apprêtent à partir pour le marché
de gisors
et on dirait qu'un avion qui se casse la
gueule non tu rigoles toi c'est une plus
de 14 juin son truc là ah non alors
merde je vais prendre mon appareil photo
bon je vais voir sur place - joignent
élabore
déjà j'étais dans la voiture pour
maintenir l'accélérateur au fait qu'il y
avait pu la démarreur sur cette voiture
et ce à son volant vous avez vu quelque
chose qui est tranquille mais a perçu
comme une boule qui descendait du ciel
une traînée lumineuse on appelait ça
vous avez décidé de j'ai décidé d'aller
voir ce qui se passait sur place comme
je suis dit on ne sait jamais même s'il
ya quelque chose parce que ça je peux
être utile
peut-être simplement par curiosité aussi
pendant ce temps salomon et jean-pierre
janvier a été remonté chercher de la
marchandise et salle au moins un
appareil photo alors l'objet des parties
de sur la droite là bas est descendue on
oublie comme ça savez quelle forme d'une
traînée lumineuse à peu près à quelle
distance ou pensé que c'était les
autorités ont estimé 3 400 mètres j'ai
démarré je suis sorti du parking est
arrivé au niveau de la route
il n'y avait plus rien alors j'ai
continué où j'ai décidé de faire
demi-tour laborde est arrivé à ce niveau
là j'ai aperçu lui aussi n en chantant
la et la voiture à ces arrêtés
la petite boule elle est venue se mettre
sous le capot je me suis retrouvé dans
le brouillard
[Musique]
non j'ai essayé de sortir les portières
étaient bloqués
je me suis endormi
à quoi va ressembler l'objet que vous
avez aperçu dans le ciel
c'est à dire que bon vin de temps
c'était blanc opaque et puis bombasse ça
faisait comme un cigare lumineux 1dans
blanc opaque ça faisait comme en cigares
qu'il descendait tout doucement en
direction du champ choo moi ce qui m'a
fait penser une fusée qui adore juillet
c'est qu'à la fin c'était pas très net
ça faisait pas un cigare vraiment une
femme rectiligne ça c'est très net à
l'avant et à la fin c'était très flou
donc effectivement je ne sais pas moi
une boule de feu conquis décembre et qui
ferait une trame derrière moi je me suis
mis à la fenêtre pour voir
éventuellement s'il restait des traces
de leurs fusées et bon bah là il y avait
plus de trace de la fusée mais par
contre y avait bien des traces de la
voiture sur le côté gauche de la route
et cas les monstres à faire descendre
pour repousser la voiture que c'est tout
ce qu'on avait gagné jusque là selon moi
y avait que ça et vous c'est le manque
est ce que vous avez vu où j'ai vu et la
voiture de l'autre côté avec en alo'o
pas dit au travers de la route
j'ai appelé jean pierre en lui disant
bon mais ça passe des trucs bizarres
moi je dis ok ok on va là on voit
pousser la voiture on verra bien après
et on est une fois arrivé donc la
bassure sur le terre-plein kohout invite
vision de la route complète là
effectivement j'ai constaté aussi que la
voiture était complètement prise dans
une dans une sphère de brouillard il y
avait trois trop cas je me souviens plus
choix précis là-dessus trop quatre
petites sphères qui tournait tout autour
bon calme ça s'est passé très vite
les spurs sont incorporés à la grosse et
à ce moment là quand tout a été lâchée
plus qu'une seule map
et comme un énorme cigare qui est sorti
sur la gauche de la sphère et qui qu'a
fait office d'aspirateur tout le restant
s'est engouffré dedans et c'est reparti
à une vitesse pas possible et là on
s'est précipité à la voiture c'est là
qu'on a vu que franck avait disparu il
ya un deuxième point c'est quand on ne
sait en bi la con et dès qu'on est
arrivé à la voiture la voiture était
plus sur la gauche de la route mais sur
la droite et en biais entre temps il y
avait un déplacement de la voiture aussi
y avait à hauteur de la portière côté le
chauffeur une petite boule celebros
comme ça la pâlit
encore ne sais pas comme une boule d'une
balle de tennis une balle de tennis -
qui seront quand même d'apparence une
consistance oui mais toute blanche très
lumineuse et ce bout là c'est le tour de
la voiture et la portière s'est dans un
premier temps ouverte et refermer et la
voiture a donc comme si quelqu'un la
mettait en route deux fois de suite
avant alors que c'est absolument
impossible ce qui avait pu démarrer en
du tout bon et après donc cette boule a
fait le tour de la voiture elle à
l'essai à la salle et une fois que le
monde puis deux coups de contact qui ont
été vite pour essayer de démarrer la
voiture
le lacet c'est refaire l'autre sens a
refait une boule qui repartit à une
vitesse pas possible et la voiture est
exactement la voiture n'a absolument pas
bougé elle absolument rien d'anormal
dessus et aucune trace de forme
absolument aucune trace mme geagea c'est
assez troublant et vous êtes réveillé un
quart d'heure après pour moi vous étiez
vous à cet endroit là la voiture avait
disparu
ah ouais ça faisait huit jours qu'est ce
qu'on pensait en voyant abat sur la voie
je croyais moi qu'on me l'avait volé
tout simplement qu'on aime et qu'on
m'avait mis dans le fossé écriture mais
les frais la voiture alors j'ai décidé
de rentrer chez jean pierre lui annoncer
la nouvelle quoique on n'avait qu'une
marchandise des puits d'eau et le puits
n'était pas là alors je serai chez
salomon et puis mais je cliquais le topo
exc
je voulais pas y croire puis jours ça
faisait beaucoup et c'est aux
informations qu'on a eue de sa
réapparition
c'est donc ce fameux coup dans un
premier temps c'était un coup de fil
anonyme d'un golf de ma fenêtre j'ai vu
une boule la boule est reparti à la
place il y avait un bonhomme je les ai
suivis des yeux et il est rentré chez
jean-pierre travaux donc c'est franck
fontaine
ça c'est un coup de fil anonyme qui a
été envoyée rtl bon on nous a pris on
nous a fait prendre connaissance de ce
coup de fil et suite à ça bon bah c'est
pas bien compliqué on le comme le gars
partent au boulot il n'y a pas
énormément de gens dans l'immeuble qui
partent au boulot à 88 du matin il a
suffi de monter la garde pendant trois
quatre jours que l'on a fini par
rencontrer et vous a confirmé ce trahi
la confiance et ouais et croiser plus
exactement mais il a vu une énorme
sphère et qui s'est posé pas d'après lui
ça faisait entre 2 m et 3 m de diamètre
qui s'est posé dans le champ et puis qui
est reparti il dit je dois dire que le
bas on est sorti on n'est pas sorti vial
est reparti à la place y avait un
bonhomme
[Musique]